あっ//
カ゚ッッ
くあぁぁぁ
くやああぁぁぁぁぁくきゃぁぁ(発狂タイム)
ぬおああぁぁぁぁぁぬああぁ(発狂タイム)
ちょっと、最近の僕のブームの話をするんですけどぉ
固定でカメラを置くというより、手で持ちながら動画を撮るっていう
皆さんお元気でしょうか、9月に入って
学校(が)始まって
嫌になってない?( ･´ｰ･｀)ドヤァ
わかるZEその気持ち
俺も学校嫌だったんだよ
だから、夏休みの宿題なんて
したことなっかたZE☆( ･´ｰ･｀)
※皆はちゃんとしようね。
さて本題に移りますか
皆さん動画のタイトルを見てもらったと思うんですけれども
休みます!!!
あの、全然大したことじゃないですよ。
別にYouTubeが嫌になったとか
やる気がなくなったとかとは全く別なんですけども
なぜ僕がTokyoに来たかというと、そもそも忙しくなったというのが原因の一つとしてありまして
その忙しさが丁度、今ピークをむかえていまして
で、もう事前にその忙しさが来るということを実はわかっていてですね、僕は
わかっていてちょっと早めに東京に来て、
忙しくなる前に沢山動画を撮りまくって
実は、一日に三、四本(動画を)撮っていたんですよ。
ちょっと前までね。
で、動画のストックをめちゃくちゃ作りまくって、もう..万全な状態で
さあ来い！
忙しいの
来　い　！
俺が、この俺が、
全部受け止めてやるよ！
て感じで、もう、、、
万全な状態で挑んだんですけれども、
ごめんなさい、ほんとそれだけなんです(笑)
ほんとそれだけ×2なんですよ
できれば毎日(動画を)出したいなとは思ってて、
頑張ってストックをつくってたんですけども
いよいよ、いよいよ動画のストックが無くなり、
動画を撮る時間がほぼ無いし
『ほぼ』というか、もう『無い』ですね。
ストックも切れてしまい
遂に僕には、
ちょっと正直どうすることもできなくない状況に陥ってしまった訳なので、
いつも動画を楽しみにして下さる方に心配されるなと思ったので
こういう理由があるんだよということを説明させて頂いてます。
という意味もこめて、動画投稿をお休みさせて頂きます、という話です。
ごめんね、タイトルだけ見ると(投稿を)止めるのかと思う方もいると思いますが、動画は
止めませえぇん！！！(ジャスティス)
止めないですが、できれば動画を投稿していきたいと思います。
今頑張っていることに全力をだしたいので
まあ、もしかしたら今後動画を出せない日が多々、あるかもしれません。
できれば出したいと思っています。
撮れたら出すと思うんで、
質問コーナーもすいません、バタバタしていてまだ撮れていません。
非常にそこは申し訳ないと思っております。
動画を休んででも、小指ぶつけたいと思うんで、
まあまた、この忙しい期間が終わったら、通常運転に戻ると思うので
いつも見てくださるみなさん、
心配しないでください。
僕は元気にやっておりますので、
ちょっとね、お休みが増えるかもしれないんですが、
忙しいのが終わったらしょーもない動画バンバン出していこうと思っているんで
暫し、僕が修業に出ると思っていただいても構わないと思っています。
最近変わったことというと、
朝起きるのが凄く早くなったことぐらいですかね。
あと、忙しすぎて遊戯王やめたという話です。
もう暫し、お待ちください。
それまで俺頑張るよ！
頑張るよ俺、頑張るよ俺！
待っててくれると嬉しいです。
以上今日のs...
セカンドじゃねえわ。
取り敢えず、今できることを頑張って、余裕があれば動画を出していきたいと思います。
というわけで、お休み頂きます！